KASLIN FIELDS: Kubernetes
is an open-source container
orchestration tool, which
has gained immense popularity
over the last several years.
As more companies began
to adopt Kubernetes,
there came to be a demand
for Kubernetes to be
provided as a managed service.
That's where Google
Kubernetes Engine comes in.
I'm Kaslin Fields,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at
Google Cloud, where
I focus on Google Kubernetes
Engine, or GKE, as well
as open-source Kubernetes.
And today, we're going to take
a look at some GKE essentials
around the different
types of cluster
modes available through GKE.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kubernetes is a platform
for running applications
by using the Kubernetes
software to create
a cluster of
machines, allowing you
to run your applications
while abstracting
the hardware that the
applications are running on.
When running open-source
Kubernetes clusters
from scratch, there are a number
of components of the cluster
itself which you will
need to understand.
These include the control
plane, which itself is made up
of several
components; as well as
provisioning and management of
the underlying compute nodes;
security and networking
configuration of the nodes,
as well as the
cluster as a whole;
patching and upgrades of
both the cluster software
and the compute nodes
that make up the cluster;
monitoring or observability
components, as well
as management tools, such
as policy-configuration
capabilities; scaling tools,
such as pod-level and cluster
or node-level autoscalers; and
availability and reliability
capabilities and tools.
Some of these components are
built into Kubernetes itself
and some are essential
capabilities which
may require additional tooling.
When running Kubernetes
from scratch,
you will need to develop
a level of proficiency
across all of these
categories and be prepared
for the maintenance,
configuration,
and exploration running a
do-it-yourself cluster will
require.
Google Kubernetes
Engine, or GKE,
is a managed Kubernetes
service from Google Cloud.
It allows you to spin up a
Kubernetes cluster quickly,
with many of the more complex
components of the system being
deployed and managed by Google.
This way, you can focus more on
running the applications that
matter to you on Kubernetes,
rather than spending
as much time understanding
Kubernetes itself.
There are two modes
of operation in GKE.
Each is designed to allow users
different levels of involvement
with Kubernetes itself.
Both Autopilot mode and
Standard mode GKE clusters
take some of the management
overhead of Kubernetes clusters
off your hands.
Standard mode offers a
higher degree of control.
The Kubernetes control plane
and some other considerations
are handled behind
the scenes by Google,
but you will still need
to manage the nodes
of the Kubernetes cluster.
GKE Autopilot mode provides an
even more hands-off experience.
With smart defaults and even
less management overhead,
GKE Autopilot lets you have
more time and resources to spend
on your own applications.
If you want minimal
cluster-management overhead
in order to focus more of
your time and resources
on the applications
you need to run,
you may prefer GKE
Autopilot mode.
Autopilot mode GKE clusters
provision infrastructure
resources as needed for
Kubernetes workloads.
This means that you pay
per-pod or per-workload, rather
than per-node.
The nodes of the
Kubernetes cluster
are automatically
provisioned and managed,
which means that there
should be no need
to dedicate time and
resources to node management
and upgrades.
Any infrastructure autoscaling
will be handled automatically
by the Autopilot mode cluster.
However, you'll need to
configure any desired
autoscaling at the
workload or pod level.
If you've been using
Kubernetes for some time
and have developed skills and
processes that require greater
control and insight
into the cluster,
you may prefer Standard mode.
In Standard mode, the control
plane and some aspects
of monitoring and management
are handled for you,
but the user still must manage
the nodes of the Kubernetes
cluster themselves.
This means that,
in Standard mode,
you'll pay per-node for the
instance types that you select.
Standard mode
clusters will require
you to dedicate some time and
resources to node management
and upgrades.
For securing and maintaining
your GKE Standard mode
cluster's worker nodes, be
sure to familiarize yourself
with the "GKE
Hardening Guide," which
is available in the Google
Cloud documentation.
All four dimensions
of autoscaling
are available to
standard mode clusters,
but you'll have to manually
configure any desired
autoscalers at both the
workload and infrastructure
levels for each cluster.
As a managed Kubernetes service,
Google Kubernetes Engine
provides users
with an easier path
to getting started running their
applications with Kubernetes.
Between Standard mode
and Autopilot mode,
GKE provides different levels
of control and flexibility,
depending on how
hands-on teams want
to be with managing their
Kubernetes clusters.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
You can get started with GKE by
visiting Google Cloud Console
and checking out
the links below.
And stay tuned for our next
videos, where we dive deeper
into GKE topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]